good
[Music]
hello how are you doing he and jaramillo
with the most outstanding popular
for today tuesday september 15 the
metropolitan police said that a man
was stabbed to death in an
apartment last night this happened
around half past nine in flamengo  and
keep rest detectives said
a man living inside an
apartment called his mother
telling her he had killed her
haze during a fight when
officers arrived at the scene found
a man in his thirties with a machete
and placed the victim under arrest  he is
a man in his 60s anyone
with more information please
contact the authorities a
henderson company that organized the
campaign event for president trump on
sunday received a fine so it is an
inspector observed that extremen and
factoring violated six orders
emergency for the cover the fine is
three thousand dollars the republican party
of nevada estimates that there was in it
Around 5,500 people take place, which is
prohibited since
meetings
of more than 50 are not allowed due to the pandemic
and the beautiful golden knights end
their dream of reaching the
technical final in the fifth game played
last night by the team from the  vegas started with
a score of 2-0 but de ales
quickly turned around in
overtime the vegas golden knights
ended up losing the series 3-2 and
now we turn to the weather forecast
for today we will have
nice temperatures with a high of 100 degrees
however as we approach the
weekend the winds return to the valley
have a great day I am sali
jaramillo and this was the spanish edition
[Music]